[Musica]
immaginate di trasferirvi a londra tra
dieci anni
come vi sposterete in città e se invece
resterete a pordenone
una mobilità veloce comoda
accessibile economica è un elemento
insostituibile del nostro stile di vita
le grandi rivoluzioni della mobilità
sono state guidate dalle grandi
innovazioni tecnologiche
il treno la bicicletta
l'auto l'aereo e ciascuna di queste
rivoluzioni ha portato a un incremento
della quantità e della distanza di
spostamento
il treno sia inserito in modo gentile
sia nella vita delle persone che nel
panel panorama nel paesaggio al punto
che ancora oggi prendiamo il treno per
andare a scoprire posti bellissimi
immersi nella natura
l'auto ha avuto un impatto molto
maggiore
che ha ribaltato l'economia lo stile di
vita l'urbanistica
il boom industriale il boom economico
del dopoguerra
l'asfalto che ha coperto le nostre
strade i quartieri di villette attorno
alle città i centri commerciali
sono tutti figli dell'automobile
l'automobile è un mezzo di trasporto
ma è anche uno status symbol racconta
chi sono che ruolo nella società che
cosa mi piace
l'attuale modello di mobilità non è
purtroppo sostenibile questo lo
misuriamo nell'inquinamento nel costo
energetico nell'utilizzo delle risorse
nel tempo impiegato per gli spostamenti
nella spesa supportata da ognuno di noi
quale mezzo di trasporto ci aiuterà a
superare questi limiti e sarà al centro
della prossima rivoluzione della
mobilità
purtroppo nessuno
né le auto elettriche né quelle
automatiche né i droni nelle bici
elettriche nessuno di questi ha le carte
in regola per avere un impatto tale da
ribaltare la mobilità la prossima
rivoluzione della mobilità non avrà al
centro un nuovo veicolo ma sarà spinta
da due fattori da una parte la
consapevolezza e dall'altra i dati o
meglio per noi utenti
lo smartphone partiamo dal secondo lo
conosciamo tutti solo in mano adesso
trasferiamo con lui un sacco di oro ogni
giorno lo smartphone è per noi la porta
d'accesso
alla conoscenza delle alternative
la porta d'accesso fisica le alternative
quando acquistiamo il biglietto ma è
anche lo strumento che ha reso la
tecnologia che ha reso possibile alcune
di queste alternative più recenti con lo
smartphone
sappiamo che strada prendere
acquistiamo i biglietti sblocchiamo le
porte delle auto in sharing piuttosto è
che
sblocchiamo un monopattino
con lo smartphone pe notiamo la corsa di
huber ed huber stesso è stato reso
possibile dal fatto che tanto gli
autisti quanto i passeggeri hanno a
disposizione uno smartphone un fenomeno
analogo è successo con il car pooling
quello che noi conosciamo col nome di
bla bla car
esisteva come concetto dagli anni 70
è venuta fuori una piattaforma online
applicazioni e così via e possibile
mettere in comunicazione la domanda e
l'offerta tempo
rapido e comodo è possibile lasciare un
feedback e quindi dire se l'autista è
stato bravo e se mi ha portato con una
macchina comoda e pulita
similmente il peer to peer car sharing
ovvero noleggio di auto fra privati
un boom
nell'ultimo paio di anni o un'auto non
la uso tutti i giorni la metto al
servizio di chi ne ha bisogno ovviamente
a pagamento questo mi trova su una
piattaforma viene da me è una cosa
funziona
passiamo alla consapevolezza la
consapevolezza di che cosa la
consapevolezza che spostarsi di meno e
meglio o meglio che non è che perché
abbiamo tante alternative e spostarci e
poco sta poco e comode così via che
dobbiamo spostarci di più
il trend è già partito alla mobilità
negli ultimi anni non è cresciuta come
nei precedenti
possiamo leggere 5 fenomeni che stanno
spingendo in questi ultimi anni questo
nuovo trend il primo la ricerca di posti
di lavoro sempre più vicino a casa il
secondo la combinazione di smart working
o settimane corte da quattro giorni il
terzo l'utilizzo di strumenti di
comunicazione al posto di miss di
trasferte di lavoro
il quarto gli acquisti on line e il
metro di questa di questo boom non è
solo nella quantità di furgoni sulle
nostre strade ma è anche nella crisi dei
centri commerciali fuori città
il quinto il fenomeno della bicicletta
per turismo per spostamenti quotidiani
per gite fuori porta al fine settimana a
spostarsi in bici significa ridurre
l'estensione della mobilità
qui direte è una tua visione no
per dimostrarvelo prendiamo come punto
di riferimento come esempio la città da
cui partono i trend la città da qui
partono i treni in europa tende ad
essere londra e londra è anche la città
in cui si tende a perdere più tempo
quotidianamente per gli spostamenti
78 minuti medi per abitante nel 2018 una
fetta importante del tempo
effettivamente utilizzabile per una
persona
a londra il picco della mobilità per
abitante è stato toccato nel 2016
poi ha cominciato è cominciato un lieve
calo è venuto al covi la mobilità è
crollata la mobilità sta risalendo ma la
risalita a londra è molto più lenta che
in tutte le altre città del regno unito
perché perché laddove il disagio per lo
spostamento e maggiore sarà il posto in
cui le persone cercheranno il più
possibile di non ritornare sul posto di
lavoro o di spostarsi di meno
dove leggiamo questo calo lo leggiamo
nelle ore di punta
leggiamo nelle ore di punta soprattutto
il lunedì e il venerdì che non a caso
coincidono con i giorni in cui chi ha
l'opzione della smart work in gola
settimana corta non va in ufficio
il calo non è uguale per tutti è molto
più marcato nei quartieri più ricchi e
molto meno netto nei quartieri più
poveri perché nei quartieri più ricchi
che le persone hanno più facilmente
l'opzione dello smart work in rispetto
ai quartieri poveri d'altra parte chi
vive nei quartieri poveri tende ad avere
meno frequentemente l'orario di lavoro
coincidente con quello da ufficio quindi
si sposta prima oppure dopo l'ora di
punta il risultato e che soprattutto
lunedì al venerdì
i picchi di domanda di mobilità del
mattino e della sera si sono livellati
al punto che alcuni operatori ferroviari
cominciano a pensare di programmare
lunedì e il venerdì un servizio simile a
quello del sabato ovvero costante nel
corso della giornata
l'altro lato di questa medaglia
è la mobilità del fine settimana ci si
sposta di meno durante la settimana sia
più piacere più voglia di andare in gita
al fine settimana quindi il fine
settimana invece sono già stati superati
i livelli pre kovida
stesso fenomeno lo vediamo anche noi
anche qui quando vediamo la quantità di
persone all'aperitivo in centro
oppure quando vediamo la quantità di
ciclisti sulle nostre strade
spostarsi di meno per necessità
significa avere più voglia di spostarsi
per piacere
ma quindi
come
ci sposteremo a londra ea pordenone tra
dieci anni
l'impatto di questa nuova rivoluzione
della mobilità non sarà uguale per tutti
sarà molto maggiore nelle aree urbane
rispetto a quelle scarsamente popolate
e dipenderà fortemente dal lavoro dalla
famiglia dallo stile delle nostre
passioni della nostra vita
di certo ci sposteremo di meno e nel
farlo saremo molto più pragmatici e meno
legate agli status symbol sceglieremo di
volta in volta l'alternativa più veloce
più comoda più economica più piacevole
a londra avremo a disposizione il
massimo numero di alternative perché da
lì partono i trend però la capacità
delle strade ed anche dei cieli in
prospettiva di londra è limitata e di
conseguenza la spina dorsale della
mobilità nelle grandi città resterà
legata al trasporto pubblico viceversa
pordenone tra remo e nelle città più
piccole trarremo il massimo beneficio
dall'automazione dell'auto e dalle
invenzioni ad essa legate
possedere momeno auto user e sarà comune
utilizzare robot taxi per andare in
centro in modo tale da evitare il
problema del parcheggio
ci sposteremo di più in treno a lunga
distanza perché sarà più facile una
volta arrivati a destinazione trovare il
biglietto o il modo di trasporto per
raggiungere la nostra meta porta a porta
ci sposteremo di più in bicicletta
perché sempre di più la bicicletta
diventerà non solo un mezzo di trasporto
economico ma un mezzo che mostra come
noi siamo persone sensibili allo star
bene
sensibile rispetto all'ambiente e così
via
passa da essere alternativa del povero
ad alternativa trendy
ma quando partirà questa nuova
rivoluzione della mobilità
saremo noi che con la nostra nuova
consapevolezza e con l'ausilio dei mezzi
di comunicazione
sceglieremo come spostarci che tu abbia
intenzione di trasferirsi a londra o di
restare al board e non e non cambia
sarai tu
o meglio la tua scelta
al centro della prossima rivoluzione
della mobilità
ricordalo quando sceglierai dove e come
andare grazie
[Applauso]